Tom Hiddleston arrived to comic-con solo  after spending time in Australia with  Taylor Swift et's Kevin Frazier had a  quick exchange with the actor in the  hall on Saturday Tom house comecon been  so far how is it going  I think right man really really good fun  yeah Keller didn't want to come handy  just here on my own buddy the Kong Skull  Island star was a fan favourite at the  San Diego Convention he stepped onstage  and received a standing ovation from the  crowd the actor and his cast mates  discussed filming his latest project  made by the producers of Godzilla and  debuted the action-packed trailer at  comic-con this planet doesn't belong to  us  meanwhile his girlfriend Taylor Swift  was busy working on her physique the  singer was spotted heading to the gym in  West Hollywood the same day staying  incognito